Can a French person understand a Quebec
French speaker from Canada? Apparently not,
according to the many comments on my last video.
I'm French, I live in Paris, and today I want to
react to a few videos of people speaking Quebec
French and see how much of it I can actually
understand. So if you've never heard Quebec French
before, it is pretty different from the French
spoken in France. And you need to know that French
is the only official language of Quebec in Canada,
and it's because back in the 17th century,
Canada was a French colony until it was lost
to Britain in 1763. French speakers there
became surrounded with English speakers,
but they held on tightly to their culture
and their language, which evolved totally
separately from the French from France.
And as a French person, one of the questions
I had when researching this video is: how is
Quebec keeping their language alive when there
are so many English speakers around them? And
to understand that, let's watch our first video.
First of all, I want to say that I
understand everyone very well. Like,
there's over 8 million people in the province
of Quebec, so it's one of the most well-known
ways of speaking French. Everyone who
just spoke here has a very understandable
accent to me as a French person, even though
you'll see there's quite a few differences.
So that's really interesting to
me — that especially in Montreal,
more and more people have to speak English
at work. And I have found in my research
that there's a lot of talk on how to keep the
French language alive. And you know, I also
relate to what this girl said, because
it's not about refusing English,
but it's more about keeping your culture,
your language, and your identity.
It feels like there's a big gap between
Montreal and the rest of the province. Like,
66% versus 84% is quite a big gap. And since we're
on the topic of the rest of Quebec, let's now make
it harder for me and let's try to understand a
Quebec accent of someone who's not from Montreal.
All right, this is very hard for me. I get the
context — you know, he's a fisherman out of the
beautiful Îles de la Madeleine — but I don't
understand too much. So let's put subtitles on.
It is tough, but I feel if I train my ears,
I would 100% understand him. And I don't know
about you, but I feel his accent reminds me
of the Cajun French speakers from Louisiana,
which I already made a video about.
And it's so interesting to me to see
how many different accents there are.
And just know as well that there's so
many different French speakers in Canada.
Today we're going to focus on Quebec French,
but if you like this video, I might make more.
Also, I just feel I need to share this,
but every person from Quebec that I've met
told me that French people from France often
found their accent funny — which seriously
makes me feel a bit sad and disappointed.
Because Quebec French and other French accents
are 100% valid ways of speaking French to me.
And also, I want to add that it's not just
these people. Some French people love making
fun of accents. Like, I personally remember when I
moved to Paris from the South of France all these
years ago, there were a few Parisians who made
fun of me for having a southern accent. Like,
I remember I couldn't say a word without having
those people laughing at me. And I think even 15
years later, I'm still a bit salty about it.
I just wish people would approach differences
with a bit more curiosity, because it
just makes life way more interesting.
All right, one thing I did know about Quebec
is that they have so many expressions that
are different from the ones we would
use in France. So let's check them out.
In France, this would mean like you fell.
Yeah, I knew this one as well. There's a few
that kind of mean something different in France,
but I think I would understand in context.
Also, I love "magasiner" because in France,
we would use a mixture of
French and English — like,
we would say " faire du shoppingshopping"
with a French accent. And unlike Quebec,
in France we're really famous for our very weird
use of English. Like, instead of translating movie
titles, we give them a weird English title
and then we say it with a big French accent.
Like in France, this movie is not "The
Hangover" — it's "Very Bad Trip." But in Quebec,
it's "Lendemain de veille," which sounds so
much nicer in my opinion. And Quebec seems
to translate so many more things into
French, which, in my personal opinion,
is really nice — because I cannot stand the bad
faux English in France anymore, especially in ads.
Like seriously, they can be ridiculous sometimes.
In any case, I really love all these differences.
If you're going to travel abroad soon,
you need to hear about today's sponsor:
Airalo. With Airalo, you can buy affordable data
plans around the world through eSIMs in over 200
countries and regions. I've been using them for
over 2 years, and they are my favorite travel
hack to have data on my phone when I land.
I recently had to go to the Philippines for
a wedding, and I installed my eSIM on my phone
before getting on the plane. And when I landed, I
just had to activate it to have data on my phone.
I didn't have to worry about finding a Wi-Fi
connection or looking for a physical SIM card.
One thing I really like about Airalo is that
they have so many different locations available,
so it really adds peace of mind for me. Like,
I know I have one less thing to
worry about when I'm traveling.
You can even use my code LUCILE3 to get $3 off
your first eSIM. They also have regional plans
as well — you can buy their Europe eSIM and
get data in 42 countries for the duration of
your trip. If you want to try it, you can download
the Airalo app using the link in the description
or scan the QR code and use my code LUCILE3.
So one thing I knew about Quebec is that they
really go the extra mile to promote the
French language, and sometimes it's done
in ways not everyone agrees with. And
we will not really get into that today,
because this is supposed to be a fun and light
discovery of the language and the culture.
But one way I really found interesting though
is the French classes that are offered to new
immigrants who don't yet speak French. And here
I found this amazing documentary that follows a
group of people from all over the world who just
arrived recently in Quebec and are trying to learn
French in 6 months — which can help them with
job opportunities or getting permanent residency.
Okay, so what I love about this class is that
it's very concrete. Like, it's not just grammar
and vocab—it's all the situations you would
encounter in your daily life if you had just moved
to a country. So like, going to the restaurant,
finding an apartment, finding work. And that's so
important because moving to a new place when you
don't speak the language can be very intimidating.
This teacher seems awesome. I don't want
to spoil the ending of the documentary,
but he's doing such a good job at
preparing them for everyday situations,
which is truly what you need if you're learning
French in six months instead of focusing on
trying to be perfect. And I found that so
interesting, that there's different programs
to help people learn the language when they come
to Quebec. And they also have official programs
for people who already are French speakers.
Like, in France, there's often some official
meetings that are organized by Quebec to
promote French immigration to Quebec. And
I know that there's a lot of young French
people who want to come to Quebec—Montreal
in particular—because they make it so easy for
French people to come and go there, with even
having a specific type of visa which makes it
easier for French speakers to come to Quebec.
I personally know a lot of French people who have
spent at least six months in Quebec, either for
work, for an internship, for their studies. And
it's often seen by French people as an easier
way to discover a new culture since we speak the
same language. But it's not always easy, as we're
going to see in this next video, which is a French
documentary about French people who are coming to
Quebec in search of good job opportunities. And
here we're following this guy who is applying to
different positions in cafés and receives feedback
on cultural differences and how to find work.
Okay, so this is so interesting that he's
receiving that as feedback, because there
are so many English words at work in French.
Like we said: meeting, email, customer success,
sales—all of these words, we say them with a
French accent. All right, let's keep going.
It seems to be quite a big cultural
difference. It's true that in France,
as a society, we're still very
formal. We value education a lot,
and here it seems clear that—at least for this
guy—there seems to be a difference in culture.
And even if you speak the same language,
you still need to adapt. It's not because
you can understand what someone says that you
don't need to make an effort to adapt to their
culture when you're coming to their country.
All right, now let's see it from a Quebec
perspective and watch this video
by a French creator that I love,
who went around and asked people from
Quebec what they thought of French people.
This is so true. French people love
to complain and critique stuff.
Also true. I feel personally attacked by that.
Yeah, that's also a thing. French people...
I don't know if that's the case—if you're
from Quebec, let me know. Do you say we're
cousins as well? We always say that Quebec
people are cousins. We say "nos cousins québécois". So let me know,
if you're from Quebec—are we? Are
we cousins? But I do feel this way.
Loved those rapid fire questions, they were
so funny. And you know, I think it's the
perfect way to end that video. It was so fun to
discover the language and the culture of Quebec. And now I just need to travel here!
French parts non validated/in-progress
Tous les jeunes adultes que nous
interpellons ici à Montréal intègrent
l'anglais dans leur vie courante. Moi,
j'écoute toutes mes séries en anglais.
Même dans ma tête, quand je parle
avec quelqu'un, je vais penser en anglais.
selon un rapport de l'office québécois
de la langue française, le tiers des
Québécois de dix huit à trente
quatre ans préfère travailler dans un
environnement bilingue. À peine
cinquante huit pour cent travaillent
essentiellement en français, en diminution
constante depuis deux mille dix.